[Musique]
messieurs mais est ce qu'on vous a déjà
dit que vous étiez vous au chaud
pourquoi
souvent ça fait plaisir oui vous y
croyez mon surnom ça vous plaît ça me
fait pas grand chose
très dur pour le défenseur quand j'étais
jeune mais fait maintenant l'uniforme ça
arrange beaucoup
est-ce que des fois vous en déjà dit
dans la vie vous étiez vous ça nous est
arrivé oui
baj de toute façon je ne trouve pas beau
c'est pas mal mais ça n'est pas à moi
d'en juger madame si ma femme
havas est il ya quelqu'un croit et qu'on
vous le dit c'est important
oui bien sûr mais enfin on le sait est
un peu soi même nom pourquoi parce que
je suis beau je me vois pas je pense que
ce n'est pas une chose désagréable mais
c'est beaucoup plus important pour une
femme que pour un homme
non non je ça vient pas de moi c'est
bien comme ça alors je m'intéresse pas
dont le mari s'en vont être veut ça
normal que je fasse pour eux le devoir
conjugal dit pourquoi je tends sont
prêts les femmes pour superman
si je trouve pas ça depuis mes 20 ans
c'est à dire que vous charmer ils vont
me fait le plus beau compliment qu'on
puisse faire à la wii pas prendre un
wagon des oui c'est vrai réellement à
cette occasion gentil on n'a pas
toujours dit si je vous le prouvez oui
mais oui la réaction naturelle et sans
préparation
ça me donne toujours envie de rire et
vous voulez me faire dire quoi au bout
de deux sets de cette affirmation
péremptoire d'ailleurs je dois dire
écoutez je vous en prie ton dans les
limites de la vraisemblance et puis
voilà une conversation qui part très mal
parce que si je m'aperçois que vous
dites n'importe quoi j'ai pas envie de
prolonger le dialogue
si vous allez me dire ça moi je le pense
mais j'aimerais savoir que ça vous fait
plaisir quand les femmes ils disent bien
sûr que quel hacker l'homme ça me fait
bien plaisir
vous avez des réponses et gens qui ont
dit ça ne me fait pas plaisir somme
qu'ils croient pas qu'ils ne crois pas
je veux dire vous vous êtes convaincre
que vous êtes beau c'est que ça te fait
plaisir
on est choyé les gens je me trouve super
moyens le jeu mouche gauche dure je me
sens vraiment pas mal du tout c'est
important pour vous que je trouve beau
non c'est même pas très rassurant parce
que d'abord j'ai du mal à y croire
et puis ensuite c'est pas une source
d'avantagés non surtout pour l'homme et
pour la femme par contre un problème
oui oui j'suis babouk de l'extérieur qui
est déjà grave mais je suis beau de
l'intérieur qu est ce qu on appelle une
belle âme mais on me l'a pas dit je
pense que c'est parce que j'ai du jeu va
tomber livré yacht en faisant des
radiologues ombra les gens qui me le
disent sont ce qu'ils m'apportent les
jeunes qui comme elle je connaisse en
beauté d'ailleurs vous êtes très jeune
c'est bien pour ça que le camping ne
paraît peut-être pas tout à fait
ridicule et je dirais aussi les
certaines jours de voyage bien que je le
revois presque plus si véritablement
chez un homme remarque devant la beauté
c'est vraiment qu'il est creux de
l'intérieur ça ne modifie pas l'opinion
que je me suis forgé depuis des années
et qui d'ailleurs se détériore tous les
matins mais encore ça maclean a pensé
que vous avez des arrière-pensées je
crois que ça n'est valable que vraiment
quand vous êtes déjà sûr qu'une femme
vous aime parce qu'autrement ci a
tellement que quelque chose d'autre et
dans le propos que je devrais savoir si
ça vous touche quand une femme vous
disent écoutez ça me touche sûrement
parce que je pense qu'elle a beaucoup
d'humour est déjà pour moi c'est une
énorme qualité chez un être humain las
une femme me dit comme ça les yeux dans
les yeux ou êtes beau jeu mais elle
manque pas d'humour ce que votre femme
vous dites souvent que cette non pas
très souvent
ça c'est bien ce prof savez ce que dix
ans dans les bras maintenant on voit que
les défauts et les qualités financer et
magic
je n'ai pas spécialement beau qu il y
avait d'autres choses qui n'intéressent
est tant mieux ça durera peut-être plus
longtemps pour ma femme mes fixée c'est
une petite déclaration d'amour conjugal
ou filiales me dire tu es beau ça tient
beaucoup plus à un moment précis où
quand je joue au tennis à la fin d'un
match de tennis ont été bons dans ce
match par exemple elle me l'a dit c'est
vrai oui bah c'est le mal choisi je
pense que peut-être je ne trouvais beau
départ oui peut-être pas uniquement
cette raison si je pose cette question à
votre femme si je lui demande si elle
vous trouve beau qu'est-ce qu'elle va me
répondre vous croyez qu'elle nous trouve
beau elle vous le dis non c'est ne
trouve pas beau selon ses yeux à l on ne
resterait pas ensemble la page avait dit
ça ne m'a jamais dit qu'ils étaient
d'accord
non elle ne l'a jamais dit je ne pense
pas que ce soit pour ce motif laquelle
mais à la fois et m'épouser d'une pause
enfants autrement dit vous préférez que
l'on vous trouve intelligent plutôt que
bon j'ai pas dit ça n'a aucune
importance soit parce que moi je suis
myope et ça ne me dérange pas soit parce
que finalement la beauté masculine
c'est un plat qui ne m'intéresse pas
soit parce que vous avez
sans avoir de l'intelligence quelques
qualités mineurs qui font qu'on n'oublie
que vous n'êtes pas beau enfin je veux
dire il ya un tas de substitut à je
préférerais qu'on me parle de mon
intelligence à coup sûr ce que c'est lié
à votre avis pas du tout non pas du tout
si on a les deux alors ça c'est
formidable
enfin on peut être d'une laideur très
intéressante est remarquablement
intelligent je sais c'est valable pour
les hommes pour les êtres humains
général enfin une femme n'a pas besoin
d'être belle 100% enfin à autre chose
je crois qu'il faut un peu des deux je
n'aimerais pas qu'on me dise que je suis
complètement idiot mais
sa dépendance à l'étang des femmes avec
qui je suis je croyais en amont je
préfère qu'elle mettre vos d'autre de
notre forme que l'on se trouve un taux
de change constants un amalgame de dire
nos attentions à lebon elle les femmes
futé vont pas jusque là je crois elles
ont tendance plutôt à vous faire prendre
l'air intelligent
j'ai beaucoup plus d'habiles une femme
qui vous écoute parler ça c'est le rêve
alors le bas on vous laisse raconter sa
masse tous par l'admiration est beaucoup
plus payant de riz cocteau de scène très
jolie phrase à partir de 30 ans tout
homme est responsable de son visage les
actionnaires cette forme de beauté
passé un certain âge c'est bon cela doit
un peu directement liée au caractère
est ce qu'il vous est arrivé dans votre
vie d'envié la beauté chez d'autres
hommes jamais ah oui oui à certains
moments très déterminé je vais
ressembler alain delon aurait proposé
des contrats de cinéma et je sais pas
comment j'aurais pu les les assumer
d'abord parce que j'ai pas le temps puis
ensuite parce que j'ai pas le talent et
c'est là que je voulais en venir
un physique qui ne correspond pas à ce
qu'on ait réellement c'est finalement
est mauvaise physique alors je me
contente du mien qui ne trompe personne
parait-il mon rêve aurait été d'être
gregory peck
voilà si je m'étais grégory pêche crois
que j'en étais le plus heureux des
hommes
le rap c'était bien d'être d'avoir la
gueule à l'étang de sartre et la tête de
newman ça s'est passé mais je me non
fond j'aimerais turbo jaloux et le
trajet droite finalement pourquoi je dis
ça je suis en train de dire n'importe
quoi là dessus ça doit être très à
grasse et déjà être beau que de le
paravent de vent entre de ne pas avoir
de goitre de ne pas avoir ces visages
ignoble quand la plupart des français au
delà de 40 ans puisque ce sont des
goinfres et des ivrognes ça m'arrive de
naturellement de prendre deux avoir des
soins corporels comme on peut en avoir
montrant maximum parce qu'il n'en faut
c'est certain et puis oui je me lève la
tête quand même deux fois par semaine
donc vous savez nos cheveux mal coiffés
aujourd'hui mais ça m'arrive s'ils n'ont
jamais rien du tout j'ai absolument une
des stars de ce sport mais c'est pas
c'est pas pour ça je l'espère parce que
ça m'amuse où le colis soit pour rester
en forme physique
j'ai une faculté extraordinaire rentrer
le ventre va dit tout entretien pas de
gymnastique pas de jeu les clubs de rire
au nez ce n'est pas ce je m'ennuie
souverainement à faire des exercices
physiques c'est la chose la plus bête et
en plus je trouve que l'homme qui
s'inquiètent de sa beauté véritablement
quelqu'un qui aime mais n'a rien à faire
du cours tanguer accordés entre la
naissance et la mort
[Musique]